un deuxième matin sous le smog à Toronto
l'effet des feux de forêt se fait sentir
jusqu'ici à tel point que la fumée cache
presque la Tour CN et que certains
auront toi ont ressorti leur masque m95
on dirait qu'on est en enfer dit ce
torontoie la fumée a gagné d'autres
villes en Ontario y compris kingsteen et
Ottawa où le ciel orange et l'odeur de
brûlé a surpris certains résidents
une situation inhabituelle qui a forcé
la fermeture du toit du centre Rogers
pour la partie des Blue Jays de Toronto
autre stade de baseball autre pays mais
un coloris semblable New York aussi
respire mal à cause des feux de forêts
Canadiens activités scolaires annulées
vol retardée la qualité de l'air
ipir au nord de la frontière
pendant quelques heures la métropole et
même devenue la ville la plus polluée du
monde une situation sans précédent
déplore le maire
le réalisateur québécois Simon Olivier
facto et de passage à New York il décrit
une ambiance étrange mais c'est pas une
femme ça donne un sentiment
même constat pour cette journaliste
normalement basé à Montréal cette
couleur jaune orange cette brume c'est
ça aussi ça donne des allures
franchement un peu de fin du monde
New York n'est pas la seule d'autres
villes américaines sont touchées par
cette vague de pollution atmosphérique
Washington et des trois se sont
réveillés sous le smog la Caroline du
Nord aussi à plus de 1600 km du Québec
des deux côtés de la frontière les
autorités appellent à la prudence car
les prochains jours ne s'annoncent pas
plus dégagés aux États-Unis comme au
Canada de nombreux avertissements sont
toujours en vigueur alors qu'au Québec
les feux continuent de faire rage ici à
Canada Toronto